big time news today for hogwarts legacy
fans and while i can't say that it is an
official source i do think we have some
very reliable information relating to
hogwarts legacy the rolling library
which more on that in a second it is not
an official source and we're just going
to go straight to the tweet right here
because it is a big one it says
exclusive inside editions to publish the
art and making of hogwarts legacy in
september of 2022.
now we'll talk about the art book in a
second guys because yes i am super
excited about the art book but more
importantly let's talk about that date
september 2022 you're probably asking
the same question that i'm asking right
now why would you release an art book if
the game isn't out yet now i'm sure this
has been done before if we go and look
at the history of video games there's
probably been some that have released
before the game released but even if it
does i can't imagine that it would be
more than a few weeks and to me this is
a huge sign guys this is a really good
sign in some of our past videos we have
talked about september 1st being an
absolutely incredible time to release
the game simply because that is the day
that the hogwarts express leaves king's
cross to head for hogwarts now one of
the supposed hogwarts legacy insiders or
leakers whatever you want to call it on
twitter account ngt has actually been
tweeting about a september release now
you guys know i don't do videos on every
single rumor because there will probably
be new videos every day if we did that
and with these random twitter accounts
that seem to pop up and make guesses and
claim to know things about games it's
hard to know who's right and who's wrong
well it certainly seems that this is
pointing in the direction of account in
gt actually having some inside
information relating to hogwarts legacy
which means we need to take a look at
one of his or her most recent tweets
from back on february 2nd which says
recap hogwarts legacy gameplay trailer
skills and abilities coming february
march aiming for a september release
officially 2022 includes multiplayer
elements translation stage has started
and then finally sumo digital helped a
lot in the development of the game now
when it comes to the art book itself if
you follow the link that was in the
original tweet from the rolling library
it will take you to this page which says
inside editions will publish the art and
making of hogwarts legacy a companion
book to the upcoming open world action
rpg based in the wizarding world the
book will be authored by jody revinson
who is the main author of the wizarding
world tie-in books such as fantastic
beasts the secrets of dumbledore movie
magic and harry potter papercraft among
others and then i found this next
sentence particularly interesting it
says although it is not confirmed this
publication date could be related to the
video game release date which is still
unknown now i have to be honest with you
guys i consider myself a big harry
potter fan i have honestly never been to
this site the rolling library i didn't
know it existed if you read the top of
their page it says the rolling library
is an online medium that publishes a
digital monthly magazine has reported
exclusive news and has done several fan
projects such as the rolling index then
if you read their about me page i think
it becomes clear that this is a pretty
reliable source i don't know that we can
say it's an official source but based on
their history based on what they are all
about i expect that this information is
completely legit and we will be hearing
more about it in the near future now
inside editions also has their own
website they don't have anything up
about this yet however they do have
plenty of experience working on harry
potter related books you can see this
page here harry potter feasts and
festivities so they are no stranger to
the wizarding world i encourage you guys
to read all of this yourself i'm going
to include links down in the description
that will catch you up on all the latest
regarding a hogwarts legacy art book now
if you guys are new here make sure you
check out that hogwarts legacy playlist
on the right side of the screen it's
going to catch you up on everything we
know so far about the game as always
thank you all so much for watching i'll
talk to you again soon